[Música]
[Aplausos]
olá boa noite
é muito bom estar aqui com vocês
primeiro de tudo agradecer agradecer a
presença de vocês o convite eu acho que
todos nós que passamos por aqui mas se
levamos do que deixamos então é uma
honra poder dividir nossas experiências
com vocês
bom é o tema que nós vamos conversar
trocar idéias mesmo em silêncio dá a
partir daí mas muito importante também
pelo pela atenção é a inclusão através
da informação e antes de começar eu
gostaria de dividir alguns conteúdos que
são frutos de pesquisas e na verdade de
um olhar em relação à inclusão através
da informação vamos ver
a ideia em aula de medicina da origem a
negócio de impressão 3d faculdades
ajustam carga horária de cursos para
atrair alunos sentem o é nem 2015
registrou menor número de faltas em sete
anos
o brasil tem boas práticas na educação
mais um entende compartilhá-las pelo
país
o aposentado de 84 anos faz enem pela
quarta vez de busca fazem teologia jovem
da periferia de são paulo é aprovado em
faculdade à noite nos estados unidos o
executivo abandona microsoft para
construir bibliotecas infantis é países
pobres
o sucesso vem da escola o esforço
individual ativista da educação malala
tira notas excelentes antes brilhante
campanha pé de kadi atletas de todo país
respeitam livros para crianças
segundo dia do enem tem músicas de chico
buarque suemi seja mesmo mais rico dos
estados unidos mas procura reputados
fora da gente universidade além de
teresina leva o bronze na olimpíada
internacional de física na índia
dom barreto uma medalha de prata na 20ª
olímpiada império americana de quinta
como prisioneiros vencer um aluno de
harvard debate nos estados unidos
o professor amaral é homenageado foi o
guia de matemática no rio de janeiro
[Música]
todo mundo quer ser aluna da professora
carioca que ensina biologia através de
desenhos número de superdotados creche
17 vezes em 14 anos de escolas do país
o grande salto tecnológico que pode
acabar com a sede do mundo
o psiquiatra de pesquisadores de raiva
da 15 dicas para crianças éticas e
bondosa e você tem que fazer
passa o tempo com seus filhos segundo a
pesquisa
e ainda tem o exemplo
na seqüência eles dizem que fale em alta
e com som e generosidade e valores
éticos são importantes
e oportunidades para que as crianças
pratiquem a gratidão e por último em si
a verem além do próprio mundinho está
dentro do nosso universo e também os
novos valores da educação e ensino
superior no brasil que tem inovação e
internacionalização além de mercado de
trabalho
o poder da inclusão através da
informação
é por isso que vamos conversar na
verdade o mundo exige hoje que nós
sejamos transformadores sociais é super
importante a gente ter um entendimento
sobre isso e quando a gente fala de
informação a gente tem que imaginar que
a informação parada retido guardada
ela não serve pra nada nós sabemos muita
informação que simplesmente vai por isso
a informação ela só se transforma
inclusão a partir da ação a partir da
atitude
nós vimos aqui algumas manchetes de
jornais do brasil e do mundo que mostra
o como a educação especificamente tem
feito inclusão social e tem mudado o
mundo porque a nossa percepção também de
inclusão ela precisa ser atualizada ea
gente vai falar é um pouco sobre isso
nós temos hoje na verdade o mundo dos
sentidos absolutos e plenos a gente tem
é como plenitude aquilo que temos a
maioria de nós pelo menos de graça e
usamos muito pouco é a visão é o fato é
a audição é o tato mas a gente tem
também dentro disso outros sentidos que
a gente precisa também amadurecer
além dos que eu citei são percepções e
sentimentos capacidades inspiração a
idéia é atingir de compartilhar também e
é preciso que a gente tenha um
entendimento sobre isso dentro do que
nós vamos mostrar por que nós escutamos
muito informação é poder
mas se a gente diz que informação é
poder nós somos obrigados a fazer
algumas perguntas de que lado nós
estamos com quem nós queremos
compartilhar
o poder quem nós queremos usando o véu a
palavra empodera e principalmente é que
mundo nós queremos né nós nos importamos
com o que é exatamente no mundo e aí a
gente começa a entrar exatamente dentro
do nosso tema que tem a ver com economia
de atenção eu vou falar de economia de
atenção muito rápido mas serve é por uma
dica de pesquisa a economia de atenção é
a ciência mais recente desse século e
ela nos ensina a prestar atenção em
demandas de toda ordem e ela faz dentro
dentro da área da informação e da
comunicação ela ensina que a gente tenha
foco ea gente não se perca na avalanche
de informação que somos bombardeados
todos os dias e é importante a economia
de atenção exatamente por isso porque
nós temos hoje é na verdade um somos um
terminal digital social terminal digital
é porque com a internet a gente recebe
muita informação todos nós produzimos
conteúdo ea internet ela pode ser uma
grande aliada não só no sentido viral
mas no sentido de mobilização
alguns movimentos no brasil e no mundo
já fazem isso com excelência mas é
preciso ter cuidado e aí a importância
da economia de atenção que é usar o que
um palestrante de hoje é do pedex vai
dizer é usar a distração para reter a
atenção é o que diz o empreendedor
social que fala sobre isso o professor
marcos linhares
então dentro disso é preciso a gente
entender de que forma podemos agir ea
internet é só uma forma de agir
na verdade é importante falar sobre isso
porque eu acho que muito mais do que me
diz com o tento andas que eu te digo
quem tu és que muitas vezes é até
preconceituoso talvez seja importante a
gente dizer diz o que tu fazes com o que
sabes que o mundo te dirá quem tu és
então a gente tem feito muito pouco com
o conhecimento ea informação que chega
até nós é como o advogado o professor o
dona de casa qualquer profissão
como médico a gente recebe uma
quantidade de informação que termina
servindo para o fim e nós estamos
trabalhando eo restante a gente não faz
nada com ela ea informação é poder na
medida que a falta de informação mata
são mães que ainda não sabem fazer soro
caseiro são mães grávidas querendo se
livrar da microcefalia que tem que
aprender a fazer é um repelente caseiro
com álcool e cravo da índia que é um
vídeo que está sendo é muito é
distribuído compartilhado hoje na
internet são jovens que não sabem como
se proteger de doenças sexualmente
transmissíveis são jovens que não sabe
exatamente a droga faz no corpo na
cabeça e nos projectos de vida deles e é
pensando nisso é que há dez anos eu
criei o projeto de palestras língua
solta é um projeto que fala sobre
inovação projetos de vida combate às
drogas e à violência sexualidade sobre
todos os assuntos e esse nome língua
solta é porque eu acredito como a
maioria de nós eu tenho certeza disso
que o mundo é mais feito de perguntas do
que respostas
então ele é pautado nas perguntas de
comunidades de universidades escolas
públicas e privadas
e esse projeto tem revelado que com
informação é possível promover inclusão
sim e aí a gente tem feito dentro desse
projeto é incrivelmente falando porque
nós colocamos urnas onde aquele público
que vai participar coloca perguntas
histórias e testemunhos
a gente já evitou por exemplo é a
continuação de abuso sexual eu lembro
que uma vez uma vez de uma escola é eu
cheguei estava vendo as perguntas com os
professores e lá encontrei uma carta que
era um grito de desespero ea criança
falava
ela dizia tia maya eu tenho 10 anos
eu sou da série e tal b turno tal e eu
sofro diariamente abuso sexual do meu
avô kuê aquilo me tirou o sono
completamente eu fiquei de
dias tentando resolver uma situação que
à medida em que você compartilha a
informação você é responsável sim e aí a
gente se mobilizou o conselho tutelar o
ministério público eu lembro que eu
ligava para o secretário então
secretário de educação dessa escola
pública todas as noites durante três
semanas o que foi feito
o ministério público já foi acionado
tudo já foi feito quando essa criança
vai sair de casa quando esse avô vai ser
responsabilizado criminalmente
legalmente em relação a isso e nessa
situação nós conseguimos tirar pelo
menos que eu lembro nesses últimos dez
anos quatro crianças nessa situação de
abuso sexual
numa outra vez eu estava numa escola em
uma criança teve um adolescente teve um
ataque epilético ele foi retirado da
platéia e aí eu perguntei o que tinha
acontecido eu tinha responsabilidade de
manter os alunos ali pra não criar um
alvoroço né e aí depois a a diretora da
escola me disse é uma criança é
epiléptica ea mãe não a leva um médico
porque a religião não permite
e de novo eu acionei o ministério
público através do projeto língua solta
ea gente é conseguir o que essa mãe nós
pessoalmente a escola e os professores
fomos até a casa de sua mãe e nós
conseguimos sem nenhuma medida legal é
convencê la de que aquela que aquele não
era o comportamento correto assim com o
caso de abandono de drogas e não ao
suicídio porque é o língua solta também
fala sobre suicídios são todos casos
ligados a projetos de vida e dentro
disso é a gente promove inclusão no
mundo pelos próprios casos vocês podem
ver no mundo de refugiados
contemporâneos
as pessoas hoje elas não precisam só de
comida de informação principalmente
sobre várias várias áreas como nós
citamos mas são refugiados de guerras de
intolerância que caminham pelo planeta
de um lugar para o outro a esmo sem
saber exatamente para onde vão e que
precisam ser acolhidos nós vivemos uma
questão humanitária hoje que é um
caminho sem volta o mundo precisa de
solidariedade
a gente é responsável por isso e dentro
desses dessa desse projeto de inclusão é
importante é a gente perceber que muitas
vezes inclusão a gente tem a ideia
também muito restrita como informação
inclusão é só a inclusão da pessoa com
deficiência a inclusão dos menos
favorecidos a inclusão através de cotas
inclusão é incluir a todos todos nós de
algum modo precisamos ser incluídos
e esse projeto ele se pauta nisso também
não é só o desfavorecido porque
mediaticamente a gente terminou
colocando é a questão da inclusão social
de uma forma muito limitada e eu diria
até aqui não é equivocada mas incompleta
inclusão por informação que é o tema da
nossa palestra é tão simples que chega a
ser constrangedor porque você é você
dividir o que você sabe que você não faz
nada com essa informação
é a gente sair da zona de conforto e ser
de fato cidadão porque o mundo de novo
caminha para os sermos solidários com a
gente não sabe como vai ficar de fato e
dentro disso você pode desenvolver
projectos de empreendedorismo social ou
de empreendedores que acreditam nessa
aposta social particularmente língua
solta hoje é apoiado pelo empresário
silvio leite pela deputada federal
iracema portela é pelo advogado mário
roberto pereira de araújo ea escola do
legislativo
são pessoas que acreditam é que inclusão
pode ser feita através de informação e
aí eu queria falar pra vocês é do banco
do tempo e de habilidades na itália
existem hoje eu não tenho 72 cidades são
cidades do bem viver pra essas cidades é
formar em uma rede elas precisam cumprir
55 metas elas são pactuados nessas 55
metas e o que acontece na itália
são medidas de inclusão social mas
envolvendo informações sobre bem-estar
sobre qualidade de vida
sobre pré preservação e apoio à cultura
ao patrimônio serviços
infraestrutura eles conseguiram pactuar
que o mundo fica de olho um pouco é no
que está acontecendo na itália e eles
têm uma experiência do banco do tempo
que inspirou língua solta e que é o
projeto que a gente se conseguir
parceiros vai fazer no próximo ano o
banco do tempo ea de habilidades na
verdade o banco do tempo existem
experiências na holanda em portugal e no
brasil com a economia solidária na
educação que eu saiba e lugar nenhum e
ainda então a gente vai fazer é eu
apliquei um questionário de 5.000 um com
cinco mil alunos patrocinada pelo que é
um estudo qualidade de ensino ea gente
eu fiz as seguintes perguntas o que você
gostaria de aprender o que você é que é
ensinar sabe que é ensinar e como você
quer trocar esses saberes né
são perguntas o que você sabe que você
gostaria de saber o que você sabe
gostaria de ensinar e eu li esses
questionários todos os meus amigos dizem
que eu sou maluca por que eu deveria ter
botado um programa para fazer isso mas
eu não fiz eu que fiz questão de 15 mil
questionários ea gente encontrou lático
respostas como é eu quero aprender a
fazer uma caseira se uma informação de
qualidade tivesse chegado a esse jovem
antes da informação da arma caseira ele
estava querendo fazer outra coisa mas
tem coisas positivas na verdade é são
alunos ensinando para alunos tendo como
monitores professores que vão ganhar um
pouco este que eles estão precisando
vamos combinar para fazer isso e no
final do período nós vamos promover numa
praça pública naquela comunidade naquele
bairro uma feira de troca de saberes é o
brasil precisa tanto de inclusão que nós
somos a centésima ocupamos a 104ª
posição no índice de solidariedade que é
feito pelo instituto é de
desenvolvimento de incentivo social
são 145 países nós estamos na 104ª
posição e isso eu acho que é claro o que
a gente precisa dizer hoje aqui sobre
inclusão através de informação então
por isso é importante que a gente siga
esse caminho que a gente possa fazer
muito mais do que a gente faz só no
trabalho todo mundo aqui cada um pode ou
adotar uma árvore ou fazer um projeto
pegar uma informação que é uma
informação médica que a informação do
direito promover justiça através disso e
se tornarem saber o empreendedor social
que também envolve recursos né eu acho
que a ideia é essa de que informação o
oposto da informação não é a
desinformação é na verdade um vulcão de
vulnerabilidades que se cria e que se a
gente atuar
se a gente for gente e se a gente aposta
está no outro é a melhor das invenções
noé é o celular na internet não é
anestesista não é avião é o outro a
gente vai conseguir de fato fazer e aí
eu gostaria de encerrar é mostrando é
que para fazer a inclusão através da
informação é nós dependemos de pessoas
como essas aqui que nós vamos mostrar
[Música]
são vocês somos nós na verdade
a gente não precisa depender do governo
a gente não precisa da perda de gestões
a gente não precisa de aprender a gente
precisar pensar no outro olhar o outro e
aí a gente vai se inspirar porque o
outro é absolutamente inspirador ea
gente pode se através da informação de
qualquer outro mecanismo que possa
promover a inclusão fazer bonito e fazer
com que essas pessoas sejam incluídas de
alguma forma alcançar jovens que hoje
estão sendo computados através da
internet por ideologias que fazem com
que eles acreditem que precisam ser
campeã casos a gente hoje é feita bem
dessa ideologia terrorista de trainee
xuxa mas tem outros outros extremismos e
outros terrorismos e encaramos na nossa
cidade então que tal você por exemplo
promover a inclusão é dando folga para
sua diarista o dinheiro sai mais cedo
vai ficar com seu filho
vamos ver um livro comigo as pessoas
trabalham tanto hoje e nosso país
especialmente que ela não tem tempo pra
poesia elas não têm tempo para a
literatura ela só tem tempo para a
contemplação não acho que a gente tem
que olhar a idéia de inclusão ea idéia
de informação e juntos fazer bem bonito
muito obrigado
[Aplausos]
[Música]